[Applaudissements]
je vois que David Fincher est revenu en
salle après son César d'honneur remis
par la magistrale Virginie Efira et
Monsieur Pitt
oui je suis venu pour David Fincher oui
pardon d'être un peu franc dans ce
métier au moins 30 secondes oui je suis
pas venu là pour ouvrir les huîtres
je le dis à tous les comédiens dans la
salle faut s'ouvrir au marché
international
en 2023 si on pense France uniquement
c'est la fin des haricots dans 5 ans ici
c'est le salon de l'agriculture
cher David donc je suis très honoré de
m'adresser à vous voilà j'étais pas là
au début de la cérémonie parce que je
sors de tournage je
je tourne un film très important
actuellement
un film événement un film essentiel
un film coup de poing
qui s'appelle ce soir j'irai déambuler
sur les quais de Seine en espérant
apercevoir toi que je n'ai pas encore
rencontré
je ne sais pas ce que vous dit le
traducteur dans l'oreillette parce que
c'est pas facile à traduire en anglais
déjà que c'est pas facile à traduire en
français
parce qu'on a une grande tradition de
titre long dans le dans le cinéma
français voilà le français c'est pas
faire court donc vous vos films David
ont des titres cours 16 game Fight Club
les nôtres sont longs c'est comme ça
alors pour les choisir je vous donne un
petit tips les réalisateurs français
prennent la ligne de dialogue qui leur
plaît le plus dans leur scénario
tu savais que Karine ne pouvait pas
venir à la communion de timeo parce
qu'elle est coincée à Houlgate BIM le
titre
à quand un dîner chez Jean-Pierre et
Sophie on n'a jamais fêté la fin de sa
chimio sortie le 12 avril
pour les vacances de Pâques
ce matin j'ai comme l'impression que
maman n'aime plus trop la Dordogne début
du tournage du 2 à Sarlat
donc voilà je tourne aujourd'hui voilà
dans le France dans le cinéma français
ici voilà tout le monde le sait c'est un
peu mon moment où vous êtes moins au
courant mais voilà c'est mon moment
voilà je sais pas quoi je sais pas
comment on le dit en anglais I have my
Perry
mais globalement le calendrier sera plus
vite David attention il y en aura pas
pour tout le monde
j'ai un petit trou fin août en rentrant
de Grèce
mais il va falloir me le boucher
rapidement
je vous laisse décanter tout ça parce
que beaucoup d'infos en 2 minutes là
quand même
sans transition mais alors vraiment
aucune on passe au César de la meilleure
réalisation celui auquel il est attribué
vient le chercher puis nous on aura tout
le temps de discuter en coulisses
monsieur Pitt peut rester ne me gêne pas
quand je dis celui qui vient chercher le
César c'est que ça ne vous a pas échappé
qu'il n'y a pas de femme nommée à moins
que ce monsieur se fasse opérer entre
son siège et la scène ce qui est peu
probable
le lauréat sera un homme